hey really quickly before we get to the
show just want to let you know how much
I appreciate the support to people who
have not yet joined up at a lot of
credit calm /mo Club please do what's
what allows this content to be free
there's like 80% more content on the pay
wall and last chance to sign up for our
Halloween spooktacular at Texas A&M
October 31st go to a lot of credit calm
slash tour we actually opened up a new
large overflow room because tickets have
been going so quickly here's a little
sample of what you missed for those of
you who are not members enjoy the show
groundbreaking study at now claims of
tanning salons could be targeting gay
men and putting them at risk of cancer
they're only one of the services offered
at Planet Spence fitness center which
one you think about look it's still gay
and the theme throughout all of it is we
don't really report news in fact someone
actually says this is Mike revenue
talking he says quote we've sold
ourselves to the devil and he no longer
works for the news I want to get married
to her but and held up by an unfortunate
family issue her parents are supposed to
bleed racist I am a devout Christian
that hopes to raise a godly family do
you have any advice on how to approach
the situation of having a girlfriend
with racist parents did you see any
white supremacist in the audience
looking for white supremacy look foot
nice and I can't find him anywhere
in our world say have you seen a white
supremacist I would like to talk to them
please well I think David Duke still has
a Twitter profile that will reach out to
him
[Music]
the contentious relationship between
YouTube and Crowder has been heating up
in this country all the people are equal
before the law but in a few short years
all peoples around the globe were
electrified to learn that Woodfox
dreamed of but could not accomplish came
to a thundering realization with YouTube
to lightning-like targeting of
conservative voices this show
Magua but its viewers are linked
together in their cause against big
technology and their greed will defend
to the death your right to free speech
fighting for the cause like good
comrades to the utmost of our strength
mclubbe shall go on to the end we shall
fight on the youtubes we shall fight all
the Twitter's and the instagrams we
shall fight with unwavering confidence
and growing strength even in the face of
demoralization
we shall defend every channel whatever
the course maybe we should fight against
the liberal media we shall fight in the
quarantine Redditt we shall fight in the
Young Turks common section we shall
fight at the TED Talks
we shall fight with our retweets in our
lives and we shall fight with all our
tents and with everything tasteful and
we shall and if which I do not for a
moment believe this cell that its
supporters was subjugated or shadow band
in armor club beyond all YouTube armed
and guarded by the half-asian frakkin
will carry on the struggle until in
God's good time the new free online
world with all its power and might steps
forth to the rescue
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
break the grip of the YouTube Gestapo
enjoy dat ladder with crowded dot-com /
bug Club today
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the Chuck Liddell a little
drunk and high on a morning show you see
that one check the doll he's like in a
Dallas Morning Show and you sitting
there and they said who do you want to
fight next he said Tommy Morrison who
was the guy from rocky fire yeah and he
blamed it on nyquil I thought she wrote
over there I've used nyquil I've never
once wanted to fight Tommy Morrison we
have Micro on the show so looking
forward to that and they have a web
extended there with with micro drinks as
I heard it is his new book we're going
to be talking about death threats versus
appropriate boundaries as it relates to
government seizing your gun so you know
that leaves me the question of the day I
know this is a topic that leads to
clickbait headlines and people often
find themselves in hot water we start
with Ben Shapiro we'll talk about that
for a little bit quite a bit actually
most avoid it I know that okay but based
on the recent controversies when if ever
do you think that any sort of an armed
resistance to government tyranny is
appropriate and I need you guys out
there to have my back - this hasn't
taken out of context no death threats no
micro leading the news though oh by the
way talking quarterblack Garrett show me
hood pass what's up dog G Morgan Jr how
are you I'm doing well sir day one of
the day is the federal is in aged in
bourbon barrels ed the Federalist
Zinfandel there is no way he said that
that quickly faster the beer that you're
still on percocet leaves news big news
romp that all were shadowing by the way
we're going to be talking about Donald
Trump has joined twitch yeah the
president made his debut on the gaming
platform during a Minnesota rally
signaling the campaign push to appeal to
younger voters so supporters they can
actually use the app now to donate to
the campaign register to volunteer and
even join the president for Minecraft
Monday's you're not sitting good best
everybody said you right back look it
over that well let's keep building this
one
okay so brick by brick well frankly
shoots fire you see and you're gonna pay
for it headstrap hey guys in the chat
let me know what you'd like me to put in
my boat I think again alligators it's
like Asians for the chauffeur's already
so in 2020 news Bernie Sanders has
returned to the campaign trail and now
he has endorsements from Alexandria
Acacio Cortes Rashida to Laban Ilan Omar
AOC will appear with Bernie Sanders on
Saturday at Bernie's background like the
back streets back I know
[Laughter]
Sanders was so thrilled by the
endorsements he had a heart attack
credence to the recent polling data
we've talked about this that shows
Bernie making inroads with two key
demographics crazy people and terrorists
who have sex with their brothers it's so
small with a plus minus margin of error
of about a hundred percent by the
Quinnipiac poll as a Quinnipiac don't
say that word a lot I only trust
Rasmussen at Quinnipiac is frankly that
Los Angeles a robot policeman Oh police
Rove Elise officer yelled at a woman to
go away after she tried to report a
crime and instead played a song here you
go
Star Trek noise is soothing hyper come
back in sorry I had to bring off her
back he was going to some we have some
producers in here you have to sit down
Hopper state it's disturbing yeah so the
rolled off which is really interesting
when you think about it because I
appreciate it
lets everyone take a breather and we'll
we'll have someone talk with you the
issue an official report later okay HP
Robocop I think you're gonna yeah that's
okay well I will come back soon I hope I
hope you find who programmed into a
robot policeman the word spook question
about AI can they know someone had to
put that in this true yeah yeah there's
bias which I don't like I'm fairly
certain it was Justin Trudeau I'm pretty
sure to our next story here apparently
doctors need to warn women now not to
use toothpaste to quote tighten their
vaginas this comes ahead on your toes
it is a thing just like drinking bleach
to get rid of autism was a thing that we
do people actually do there are some
really stupid people and we have
defeated natural selection and I don't
know I think it's just in a new force
and yeah it opened posed natural
selection is learning lighted life finds
a way
spokesperson for the Royal College of
Obstetricians and Gynecologists say that
putting toothpaste down there would not
only be uncomfortable but it could lead
to serious damage and the organisation
felt a warning was needed after this
became it became a really big online
trend Oh influencers whatever that means
and even the Canadian Prime Minister
promoting the practice on social media
hi guys welcome back to another beauty
secret tutorial today I want to let you
in on a tip I like to use all natural
toothpaste because it's fluoride free
and has activated charcoal which acts as
a really nice detoxifier as well as a
natural whitening agent so just apply it
to your brush here and don't be shy to
use a liberal amount and just let the
activated charcoal do its thing Minister
Joe Prime Minister Justin president
Becky hey we have to go to this week's
holiday
[Music]
still need the says that we give more
credence to what's happening in
Hollywood true then what should actually
be affecting our lives yeah oh that's
surprising what do you have your iPad
there cuz I'm just gonna make sure to
you know to research things he has he's
actually typing up his official
resignation yeah I have that that's just
save draft and sent singer Ed Sheeran
because we haven't talked about him for
a week and a half
taking a break from touring and he spent
the entire time painting ah you know for
a singer ed Sheeran is a great painter
but he's only an average gay now his
preferences their oil paintings
landscapes though he says that his real
passion actually applies in
self-portraits which if you see yeah
he's like uncanny Wow
is he really so good yeah actually I
know that was just slander I was gonna
say I was looking it up just you know
from the legal perspective I met to
humanity can I send you some photos here
of his wife wait yeah I mean I think we
do have some photos of her but either
way he's giving he's giving hope to
everyone like Gerald who married up you
know I thought you were putting it up to
make the case that he's straight and
she's a field hockey player yeah
Gerald's favorite there and Z without a
doubt rap artist ja Rule my god remember
him he said that he still remains
haunted by the poor quality of prison
toilet paper comes from fate six recent
it was the next step to wiping your ass
with a brillo pad going on to add that
it was almost as painful as the time he
was raped in the prison shower with a
brillo pad late 90s early odd hip-hop
artist brillo pad rape is no
and it's unfortunately more common than
most realized as a matter of fact early
on trapper brillo pad rape is likely to
affect each and every one of us in our
lifetime startling statistics show that
at least one in four late 90s the early
odd hip-hop artists have at some point
in their life experienced brillo head
rape even more disturbing more than 90%
of these instances of brillo pad rape go
completely unreported that would mean
that at 2017 s fire festival hip-hop
artist ja Rule was raped with a brillo
pad upwards of 72 times it doesn't have
to be this way it's time to end the
stigma let us be the generation that
says enough of late 90s through early on
hip-hop artists brillo pad rape please
go to brillo pad rape em and give
generously to put an end to brillo pad
rape today yeah and that's an actual
website I don't like that I heard
laughter here in the studio it's not a
first off you're better than that
no I'm not you're all better than that
and brillo pad rape is a pandemic it's
which means it affects people on a
global scale I thought he was gonna be
pissed off at the like you just you know
you get the surprise whenever it's not
picking up and what are you talking
about a fun thing I don't know are you
speaking from experience
he's a disgusting human being in an
effort to relate to we're gonna be
talking about government and armed
insurrection and all the you know in
case this isn't necessarily your speed
there's still quite a bit more of this
speed before we change those gears so in
an effort to relate to the struggles of
its young audience actually a Sesame
Street you know Sesame Street debut
about a new puppet character whose mom
is addicted to opioids which I am
actually I'm actually supportive this
but we've known about the opioid crisis
with Muppets for a long time as we've
discussed with our office opioid expert
PJ who's actually here right now hey PJ
PJ what's what's got you so down well it
all started with a prescription for
codeine after my herniated disc surgery
next thing you know I'm performing moral
favors for a day trader in Chinatown for
half a percocet wow that is uh that is
surprisingly disgusting yeah but a
pretty dark place
last week I gave a Porto Rican could he
sit here here's a grimace sitting out
with a question okay alright well that's
that's fine we just backstage one of
your producers had a body of votes so I
had to give him a Mindy was a Mandy
candy
of course yes okay all right you you
hang in there
PJ chin up okay I don't know why I
thought his name was not PJ I thought it
was Gerald see ya well soon or not what
one sells guys listen it is important
people who are addicts we need to give
them something to look forward to
PJ you can be Gerald see once you clean
up what there we go excellent there's no
light if there's a juror it gets better
just hold on with your little four
fingers finally hip-hop producer
Pharrell Ferrell Harrell just observe
the foam on the mouth corners and then
you know it's a roller there you go he's
in the cover of gqueues new masculinity
issue yeah they're do we have the full
cover we'll bring that up for the
magazine to explore the ways that
traditional notions of masculinity are
being challenged overturned and evolved
as what they say and that brings us to
this week seven plus one so this we get
7 plus 1 8 practical uses for Pharrell
based on his GQ cover oh you don't have
to be this is a basically a public
service number set practical uses
Braille
number 7 a wonderful Christmas tree
topper lint number 6 a shuttlecock for
Giants see he serves you a bill how
about you read us numbers I like that
number 5 emergency plane exit yeah see
we
and it worked pretty well number four an
ice-cream cone for Giants so it's really
a beautiful
let's have G Morgan a resting place for
embalmed Egyptians which you know we
really could have had we could have just
said tomb yeah just back that probably
would have been a little easier number
two very very no passing hazard sign
Braille yeah
Oh safety first and the number one
practical use for Pharrell based on his
recent GQ catalog cover gay orgy
sleeping bag which seems yeah okay I
forgot the plus one the one in the
chamber to forget the one the chamber
give us one practical use for Pharrell
based on his GQ cover cancellation of GQ
subscription all right who knocked over
my pipe ooh that was you hey
quarterblack read us the winner from
this year's uh trivia contest winner is
Katherine identified oh you mean your
mother makes you nervous must be very
uncomfortable for you except for hello
that's awesome roughly identify that
a.m. is a location for this year's
Halloween spooktacular go to a lot of
calm slash tour for details okay so
everyone got that out of their system
yeah I want to talk about this this uh
this idea of people now are labeling
anyone who criticizes the government or
accuses policies of being tyrannical I'm
making death threats yeah and I think
it's a discussion that we actually
should have a lot of people don't want
to have it because no one wants to be
tarred and feathered as someone who's an
extremist we're suing Jeff it's no one
here is issuing despard's wanna be
really clear write happy Schindler but
I've heard me say this repeatedly on
good Ally covers so let's start it with
this bait oo Rourke in case you think of
another bait oh there is my bait Oh
someone's going father
I knew a bado back in junior high but I
don't think he proposed a gun buyback so
bado he repeated his demands for a
mandatory gun buyback program at the
debates this Tuesday listening to my
fellow Americans to those moms who
demand action to those students who
March for our lives who in fact kick him
up with its extraordinary bold thank you
guys
that calls for mandatory buybacks let's
follow their inspiration and lead let's
just follow their inspiration no no
doesn't matter how much of a violation
if you in rise it as long as you were
inspired it doesn't matter just do it
look at some nice watercolors oh my gosh
and just to be clear we want to make
sure that we are not taking him out of
context I encourage you to go watch the
full debates the next day when asked
about it he doubled down on his comments
in that case I think there would be a
visit by law enforcement to recover that
firearm and to make sure it is purchased
bought back so that it cannot be
potentially used against somebody else
because you would never want a firearm
to potentially be used against someone
else know that almost might negate the
purpose of fire it's crazy to use it for
its main purpose whatever violence I
want to take the knife because it could
be used to cut something it could be
used to separate objects of different
density and we need to take the knife
which is happening in heaven keep in
mind by the way while we're talking this
beta was arrested for burglary and had a
DUI fled the scene so the guy proposing
this is somebody who was burgling
brothers in the world but where's Greta
to say that he's stealing her future in
[Laughter]
okay great so be - you're not gonna do
you know I can't drink any more because
of the DUI you're not gonna live in a
house the drunk Wet Bandits the truck
went bandits he is let me so now by the
way this isn't it's important to note
even at the democratic debate I think
that's why I doubled down the next day
yeah the Democrats went out of their way
they wanted to challenge him on this and
I think this stems from but bado was
struggling I think to get one or two
percent in the woods
yeah and so you know what Democrats
obviously are pushing her this I'm just
gonna
come out and say mandatory gun buyback
gun confiscation that was a Hail Mary
Ann Democrats are going oh we can just
pick this guy off more effectively than
Jessica ever picked off Kamala Harris
Board debates ago which by the way Tulsi
Gabbard I actually think the only two
reasonable people on that stage and rank
tail said yeah but Tulsi Gabbard has no
chance she's too hot you can't have a
president who's that attractive people
we're comfortable around it notably
Justin Trudeau he's going to be
competing sizing around Mean Girls so
the Democrats went after I want to make
sure that we show clip they went after a
dork saying well okay Beto how are you
going to enforce that it's unenforceable
our fellow Americans will follow the law
yes mass shooters in parkland in El Paso
I could go on for ten minutes they don't
follow the law by definition nice and
big digis yeah you don't know how this
is actually going to take weapons off
the streets if you can develop the plan
further I think we can have a debate
about it I can't you can't debate about
it nobody can and by the way last night
I was having dinner with some friends
and one of the people at the table said
it was refreshing to hear him say
something other than thoughts and
prayers like wow but did you listen to
anything said yeah out of it made me
sense yeah it was bad policy ar-15s
aren't responsible for most mass
shootings and you can't do it I don't
believe the story you weren't having
dinner with friends you were by yourself
by myself or by yourself crying into a
hungry man I was it is interesting to
think that if thoughts and prayers are a
problem and no action dreaming about a
land in which people are just criminals
are going to voluntarily have their
firearms and then only the good citizens
will be the ones without guns that's not
fantasy you told me by the way no here's
the thing too you ceased to be a good
citizen just for holding on to your
right exactly you are now a criminal
because of a god-given right that's
going to bring us into this conversation
that I really want to talk about and
explore so knowing this you know last
week the left they had a meltdown
claiming that Ben Shapiro had threatened
to murder someone because he did say
that he would resist the Democratic
agenda if it violated basic human rights
I want you to watch the clip now full
disclosure I'm friends with Ben Shapiro
I've known him for a while I was like he
negotiated my first business contra yeah
we just met through Andrew Breitbart and
I said you know you've got a lot of
vowels and you're
last name and you seem like you can
negotiate this court workout I didn't
know Bill at the time of such Shapiro
probably a good lawyer did it very well
just what yes I am biased but I want you
to watch the clip for yourself and see
if he made a death threat in any shape
or form
there's only one reason the government
exists to protect those rights not
invade those rights
it is my rights raise my child with the
moral precept that I find to be
beneficial for my child they don't work
does not get to raise my child and if he
tries I will meet him at the door of the
gun I don't hear you well he's talking
about protecting exactly he's not
talking about threatening he's not going
out to look for beta O'Rourke he's
saying look if you come and try to
invade my base and try to tell me how to
do this I'm going to protect myself
right I mean I think the one thing I
would say that is at least
intellectually honest about what bado
saying is that he's admitting that the
plan that he has been talking about and
that other Democrats have talked about
will lead to using guns to seize other
guns from rebel who aren't using their
guns wrong and so finally admitting it
and now even the left is admitting it's
not really a plan that will make sense
in any kind of efficacy type of way
absolutely that's that's a fact the fact
is I was at Harvard and you're merely
maybe if you go into the court room and
we meet and unappetising you're using
your will do a colander kung-fu moves
I'm quite confident I played a Carnegie
Hall but I do like I know I'm just
razzing him a little bit how locked out
aloft it does beg the question when if
ever is armed resistance required or
appropriate and how is drawing a line in
the sand on that basis we need how is
that different from a death threat again
half-asian bill my lawyer not making any
death threats I am NOT issuing any call
to violence here with this segment okay
right he's not okay okay so let's go
through point one except you're having
this conversation because to think that
to think that resistance or to think
that some kind of armed resistance or
armed a violent conflict can't happen
today is naive right it's to not
understand bake the basic human
condition and it happens across the
world today by the way slavery still
happens today and we'll get back to that
this idea that we're well past that so
we don't need guns anymore
zach is so factually off being that it's
the actual rate we need firearms because
you learn to protect oneself in the
modern world is with firearms and that's
why it's a god-given right so let's look
at the history as to what in the past
throughout history humans thought
warranted some kind of resistance right
in differentiating that let's
differentiate that from senseless
violence
so one let's take an example here and
say a death threat versus setting a line
in the sand right boundary okay so one
like saying if someone breaks into my
house in the middle of the night well I
in my family are there I'm going to
protect with my firearm yeah okay
reasonable that's issuing a line putting
it drawing a line in the sin creating
boundaries the other a death threat
would be saying I'm gonna kill everyone
at the post office ones appropriate ones
are reprehensible crime yeah we look at
history there are through lines as to
when people have resorted to armed
resistance legitimately right usually it
requires the invasive removal of very
personal human rights I'll give you a
few examples here of course with the
American Revolution you can see freedom
of religion was a big one
yeah but wanted to be able to worship
freely the government was not
representative of its of its
constituents taxation without
representation now that mirrors quite a
bit what happened with the French
Revolution right we have the civil war
over slavery I would argue that's a good
thing someone was trying to say you are
going to be enslaved I'm going to remove
your right to be free and there was a
call to arms which is also why we have
the Second Amendment in the first place
right and I would just like to say a lot
of people will throw out the thing and
say you can never overcome the US
military forces like yeah that's what
they were saying about the British
whenever we started fighting that's what
they were saying in Vietnam when we had
this long protracted war and in
Afghanistan all these people
you will always outlast an out fight if
you're an insurgency it'll always happen
right you can't wipe everybody out so
people that saying you don't need those
weapons you'll never be able to do that
they're wrong not necessarily always
historically I saw captain Phillips with
Somali pirates you just need more than
one boat still waiting for that within
the international waters here in
romantic comedies they don't think it's
coming down he's high watermark he was
nominated for an Oscar where's my
failure to launch
I am gain
80-pound but you're gonna say where's my
tea I mean I think when you when you
look at the short-term the left
continues to focus on the idea that well
we'll just take a whit guns and we get
over the fact that criminals are still
gonna have guns but what is the point of
having the right to defend and if you
can't defend yourself in a means that
would actually help you let's say I mean
that the tales of and not tales the the
real-life stories of individuals who
would otherwise not be able to fight off
an intruder much less two or three or
four or five right I've had a simple
firearm even just a 22 to be able to
defend themselves and to be able to
scare our folks as a deterrent you're
saying that if you were in that
situation you do not have a right to
take any action at that point you might
as well just say lay down take your
clothes off give them a stuff it's your
obligation 2019 when people say well
they couldn't have foreseen the kind of
actually it's more necessary than ever
yeah in 2019 because it's your right to
self-preservation right you're not just
using a club at this point if you don't
have a firearm you're not going to
protect yourself and as far as the
guesswork I like to take it out of this
equation here but what rights are worth
fighting over um we have a guide to our
stars of people the Constitution and it
expressly outlines human rights natural
rights human rights as granted by God
that's what's important here majors
think it's some some imaginary being in
the sky that's fine but you still
benefit from the idea that the founding
the premise that the founding fathers
used to establish the Bill of Rights the
Constitution they said this is the
government cannot grant or remove these
rights they can only exist to protect
them so again when if ever is armed
resistance appropriate and can someone
discuss in 2019 without being accused of
a death threat speaking of death our
channel is actually still alive and well
thanks to you hit the notification bell
if you're subscribed because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
just bookmark the page new video every
single day if you want this content to
continue join my club lateral cutter
calm slash mug Club so let me kind of
make this clear and then you guys can
obviously chime in sure when would it be
appropriate let's start with when it
would be inappropriate okay when would
it be inappropriate to ever defend
yourself or mount some kind of
resistance okay
it would be inappropriate for any kind
of violent resistance due to a personal
affront due to policy differences due to
ad hominem attacks or even due to a
proposal of a policy that you think
could lead to tyranny
none of those would be appropriate
instances to stand your ground okay and
there's there's there's some nuance in
there obviously let me tell you where it
gets black and white there ceases to be
nuance the moment there is an
enforcement of policy that have
infringes upon your basic fundamental
human rights resistance is at least an
appropriate discussion so we've said
where it's not appropriate let me give
you some clear examples or I think it
could be appropriate let's start with
with beta work going house to house to
take people's guns yes which is he has
to do that right we're not talking about
an assault weapons ban you know we
should basically means like okay this
this is legal illegal
[Laughter]
we took assault weapons that was one
thing funny with the debate he said we
don't assault weapons off the street and
crime went down well use the dummy crime
was already going down last year was the
lowest year I believe for violent crime
ever you were just a blip in the overall
downturn by the way I don't think what
stopped the crime was this correlation
does not equal causation for arson just
people just using less guns because the
the pistol Caribbean yeah I don't know
how to use it now I just you know George
Harrison after helter skelter I don't
remember that one okay so that's it for
the year Gerald so uh you've broken no
law Oritel might house-to-house take let
me be quick you've broken no law it is
your personal property you have the
right to own that gun correct and
everything else the government has no
authority to infringe upon that right if
you are a law-abiding citizen right they
solely exist to protect those rights so
let me give you another example if some
person has seized control to which they
have no right decides that they want to
rewrite laws so they can simply have
infringe upon your god-given rights its
illegitimate now I won't recognize that
Justin is it just is in the same way if
someone walks into my house who's an
intruder he has not been granted
permission and like a vampire I didn't
invite him in if I do it's on me it's on
me
I'm gonna be
in the face I get it it's a rule right
if he comes in he does not have the
right to take any of my stuff including
my firearm neither does a member of the
government they do not have the right to
do that just because someone said I am
going to create a new law that's
important that's that's different from
committing a crime or foregoing your
rights because you're a felon is is that
there's obviously a structure on which
we say that if you're participating in
society right if you give up your rights
by committing crimes that are at a
certain level you're giving that up and
I get that there are libertarian friends
out there who would say that if you're
in the society you never give up the
right so there shouldn't be such things
taken I get that argument but you know
the general premise of where the
Constitution came from was that and
where we've interpreted is that you
would be able to give up those certain
rights whether its freedom going to jail
having guns taken away or the vote to
write your franchise etc and so then
ultimately the question becomes let's
take the reality of saying okay let's
say it's not the United States where
things are despite what the left would
say pretty great and then you go over to
another country where they're fighting
for freedom is that rule still supposed
to apply there oh you're saying they
have the right to defend themselves
because they need to do it right then
but not in America because we don't need
to do it right now and we will never
ever ever have to do it in the future
yeah right and and even if God willing
we never would have to but the point of
the god-given rights not only on an
individual basis to be able to defend
yourself but to be able to defend
yourself from a government that is
supposed to stem from the people and win
it now not anymore that's when you have
to have the discussion and now when I
get away from the idea of you know like
assault weapons bans but this is the
same reason that freedom of speech
people get people are shocked when I
said well it really only exists in the
United States because it's enshrined in
our Constitution and remember that lady
had change my mind she's like what are
you talking about you read them a speech
in Germany I said really yeah you're
lying
we just don't speech it only exists here
because it is enshrined in the
Constitution yeah a law like this we're
completely destroying the Second
Amendment and going house to house
moving people's guns would that be
legally unprecedented bill it would be
very it would be against the set rules
that we have right now
come from the Supreme Court about what
the Second Amendment protects and what
it doesn't and the in the line that the
Second Amendment comes from on the same
premise of the inalienable rights that
came from the original Constitution so
you know we've got the Bill of Rights
they further interpret what those rights
are and have been set down and of course
you know the states could all get
together and take those rights away to a
certain extent except at that point
would obviously believe it's out of the
Constitution and against what the
country was founded on well let's let's
I'm gonna say this isn't something that
a bridge too far for us to really
contemplate a president getting elected
and then using an executive order to try
to do something like this to circumvent
the Constitution I think that's a kind
of scenario that we can envision where
all the sudden we've broken the process
that we have in place to make sure that
the laws of the land are enforced and
that we adhere to those laws that's the
kind of what happened it's never policy
let's compared to the freedom of speech
scenario okay but let's kind of go on
that flip side of the coin here so I
have the right to speak freely that's
recognizing the Constitution what does
that mean if I am out speaking against
the government let's say I matter right
to life rally yeah okay let's just say
I'm speaking offensively for example I
don't know using your biologically
proper pronouns so so offensive cancel
just because it offends somebody doesn't
mean they have the right to punch me in
the face and I can't come up throw a
concrete milkshake I have the right to
defend myself
with appropriate force yeah equal an
opposing reaction right that would be no
different than if I went out and spoke
against the government and they sent
armed people to jail me those are
removing my right to speak freely
enshrined in the Constitution by force
I believe that in that instance it is
appropriate to defend yourself these are
extreme examples at least they would
have been theoretical examples except
for the fact that beta work brought it
to the wall as a very concrete example
he would send people house to help you
take your guns with their own guns yeah
they did it very clearly the government
has no authority and tell me what I can
and cannot say just because a new
politician says they can it doesn't mean
that I'm actually breaking the law it's
a natural law it's a human right it is
not a political policy and I'd like to
toss a bill on that a little bit people
don't understand the idea of of natural
rights human rights these are birthright
well they're the idea that the rights
themselves are outside of or
of and not given by government because
at some point when you say that the
government is the one that can create
the rights and those rights don't
pre-exists the government so not only if
you unhinge the idea of rights except
for someone who's giving it to you but
you have no way to say if a group of
people get together and say yeah you
actually don't have any rights anymore
so clean my house right I mean they just
that's that's the kind of natural
thought that led back to a democratic
lead fight for slavery you know a
century go when did I lose that right
flip is really popular right now so we
let him do it it's a one important thing
I would definitely say is it you know
because beta was already taking this to
the very end that's why we're talking at
the end about would you ever need guns
would you ever get to that point in
between here and there is the court
system yeah there is the fact that we
have the party system that we have
voting and you take the clips note
opposite of that context contact go
ahead so we have all these things like
the electoral college versus the popular
vote yes yes sir are these systems
necessarily a hundred percent efficient
of course not the natural wave societies
that things can't be efficient but the
natural system that we have in America
as opposed to other places means that if
we were to get that far we will have had
crossed so many thresholds that that is
the only option all right yeah and with
Jordan Peterson that's the whole trouble
that the compulsive and language that
they're dealing with you know so this
isn't the freedom of religion right to
worship freely yeah I don't get Muslim
Christian Jewish signs how it doesn't
matter right it is my right is
everyone's right here - I know but you
know what they careful they barely one
that lets Xenu here you know deny here
Tom your level will be off the chart has
sex with you oh lucky again
it's a Scientology sex for the dead
that's what it is it's like the baptism
for the dead only it's a Tom Cruise and
he just goes on a date with you so it's
my leave my family spiritually as I see
fit period if some random guy comes into
my church or your mosque with a gun yes
right telling you that the Flying
Spaghetti Monster has led to more Wars
than bla bla bla bla bla bla bla people
okay we get it everyone who says it's
like we understand that you took
humanities 101 edges
this is about we have the right to
defend ourselves as someone walks into a
mosque or a church with a gun why
because it's a natural human right they
cannot tell us how we can worship now if
the government does that same thing in
Saint listen I'm sorry
this is what ben shapiro was speaking to
you can't take your child of that
christian school you have to send him to
our public school
you can't teach your son that theology
it has to match our new tolerant
guidelines and they attempt to enforce
it which bado is really clear about
means people door to door with guns yeah
resistance is an appropriate discussion
at that point to have matter call to
arms not a death threat context context
context let's the young turks trying to
take this clip and say call to arms i
want to make sure we really clip the
government at that point is no different
than the man entering a mosque with a
gun to try and stop you from worshipping
freely yeah absolutely in when
government starts to take some of those
rights that we've listed it never goes
to a positive place it's never a good
thing for people to give up those rights
and also the form of the government only
goes really to get bigger and become
more powerful why would you want to
allow them to limit your rights while
they increase theirs that doesn't make
any sense at all well i'll tell you why
because you know how you're paying
premiums right now for health care that
millionaire bernie is gonna be funding
that right yes is that book sales right
to my health you know sell his umpteenth
house or his wife works hard - I don't
know figure out where ever she funneled
college I remember that college I used
to see ads for when I was a mantra I'm
getting off-topic okay again this is not
a call for violence I want to be really
clear we have to go to Mike Rowe here in
a second this is about establishing
boundaries yeah okay more importantly
it's about engaging everyone here not
only in this room but if you're watching
in a discussion about boundaries so that
we can set them before they are crossed
in order to avoid any violent conflict
alright when you set boundaries and
people know that those boundaries exist
for example if someone says listen if
I'm a law-abiding citizen and you send
someone in my house with a gun when my
family's there to try and take my stuff
whether it's my flatscreen I was gonna
say plasma I don't think plasmas I hope
that was a major each with their own
50-inch plasma
screener wealthy
oh damn unfettered capitalism noggin get
it at Walmart a Westinghouse for $40
anyway yeah but if someone for me to say
listen if someone with a gun comes into
my house to take my property whether
it's a TV or a gun no this I'm not going
to a lot I will meet you at the door
with a gun that is a boundary that is a
line in the sand that if someone knows
actually assist them in avoiding some
kind of a violent conflict because if
you don't set boundaries you're often
the last to know when you've crossed
them or they've been crossed your your
basic human rights birth rights
defending them is completely justifiable
I don't think it's controversial you
know because if the government just said
we had slavery in this country terrible
context contest slavery bad okay when I
[Laughter]
cancelled again we had slavery so it's
not in their slavery across the globe
let's say the government because bado
had an opinion he did a hardflip to
nosegrind said I don't know if that's a
term anymore I don't not sure he did a
he did a a goofy hardflip - why am i
doing like Trump practically break a
reverse alley pop shuvit to boardslide
on the wall and I am NOT a fan of the
boardslide I prefer a grinding of the
trucks what you truly see when you think
about skateboarding winding you have
noodles it's like I'm going to slide on
a and are they so object and my board
rough metal that has more friction yes
but does not slide well so you're gonna
do a thing that's more difficult despite
having the tools to do it taking away
guns from people when they would want to
fight armed he's giving me the he's
giving me the red light were to say
slavery's back you can resist that I
think it's an appropriate response to
resist it violently in that instance and
I would be with black people if they
wanted to put y'all back in Chains right
I think why because the government
doesn't have the right to enslave people
we only know that now because we fought
over that it was resistance I'm okay
with that
how do we set those boundaries that's
the question you might be asking the
good part is
we don't have to guess in regards to
this because we have the concept
[Music]
you will remember the day you had the
chance to join Marco but a mere price of
$69 for students veterans or active
military and rich too short you will be
telling your grandchildren the tale of
the opportunity that you had to support
the freedom fighters in the technology
field on the platforms but failed to do
[Applause]
break the grip of the YouTube Gestapo
enjoy dat ladder with crowded dot-com /
bug Club today the Second Amendment
guarantees your right to be armed for
your protection or the protection of
your loved ones I was able to stop
before I was able to do any real search
you can you'll still face ridiculous
civil liability with the defensive use
of your firearm
that's why you need firearms legal
protection with our 24/7 emergency
hotline and plans designed specifically
for the firearms owner firearms legal
protection is the best legal protection
you can have for self-defense
[Music]
[Music]
you're not dying you just can't think of
anything fun to do join mug living lotto
with CARICOM / mug them I always felt
sorry for kids dressed as M&Ms for
Halloween boy
that's no kid once well you have one kid
I used to talk about this instead of one
kid is like I'm Superman I'm gonna save
the world I'm a firefighter arresting
people from burning buildings and then
because the kid has a crappy mom he's
I'm gonna melt in your mouth I'm full of
chocolate it's just it's just a layup
for bullies really you might know it's
chumming for bullies all right our next
guest on that intro
wanted to get him on the show for a
while he's a very busy man of course you
know he big fan from Dirty Jobs at micro
works as his Twitter he has a new book
out the way I heard it it's basically a
collection of stories and I believe it
relates to his podcast as I heard it
which I've listened to a couple of times
very funny and he has another podcast on
Facebook I want to make sure I get this
right it's returning the favor so so
many shows and old ladies really want to
have sex with him like I'm not old
ladies like ladies like I I will tell
you this my grandmother-in-law not
surprised if you mentioned Mike Rowe she
starts doing this so and she actually
Delavan which is refer don't think she's
that hot
I don't think getting a hot flash I
think she wants to let the world know
that oh if you have him on your show
send him my way mr. Mike Rowe how are
you sir well I'm deeply flattered I'd
love to see some photographs of the
woman in question and I think she's 96
so listen I I'm no ageist doggone it and
if she's getting the vapors as a result
of yours truly then there's no there's
no option but to be deeply humbled well
I'll try and find a picture of her from
her youth because she was quite the dish
but I imagine that picture is just a
pterodactyl with Sam stone picture so I
want to make sure your book is the way I
heard it correct correct
okay and the book is explaining for
people who don't haven't seen it yet
read it the book began as a collection
of stories on my podcast which is also
called the way I heard it which began as
an homage to a guy named Paul
Harvie which some of your listeners
might recall this great broadcaster who
made history and biography interesting
by telling short mysteries around
subjects with which he was fascinated in
his own life I stole that idea or at
least borrowed it with some semblance of
permission changed the title and and
started writing these stories on
airplanes and then recording them and
then to my wandering eyes discovering
that we had a couple under million
downloads or something so a publisher
said hey it'd be great if you put this
in a book and I said okay and then my
mother said you know it would be great
between these stories Michael is if you
would share some stories of your own
youth in a in a juxtaposition of sorts
right and I said mom what do you what
are you talking about and why can't you
mind your own business because now she's
a best selling off there so of course
she has answers everything and but she
was right so what came the book is a
weird mix of autobiography and biography
truest stories of famous people I have
never met juxtaposed with truest stories
of my own misspent youth
coming together and what can only be
described as a happy serendipitous nexus
of mystery and memoir it can only be
described that way because that's kind
of Flowery the language it is it's a
little flowery and I guess now that I
think about it we could describe it
equally accurately as not massive
schizophrenic desperation I guess let's
just say good and you should purchase it
let's go that's simple let's go let's go
with this I'm literally sitting here
because I'm doing the book door and I'm
looking at my stupid device and seeing
that I'm number four on Amazon right now
and before the interview started I was
number six so role that's the power of
the show that nobody in the right mind
has any business doing I still don't
know how we get a driver's aller and
presidential candidates I'm like did you
see what we did we had Pharrell on top
of a giant Christmas tree okay so I
don't want to blow smoke here but you've
been successful in so many endeavors mr.
Elliott you've obviously done advertised
mr. micro mr. Mike mr. Mike Brooks I
think I've earned it yes you have earned
it sensing we'll go with master ro
master micro I usually prefer a coach
relationship than a master relationship
but I'll allow it so you've been
successfully done so many different
things right and in and you've been
successful in at least what we've seen
in the public eye all of them and you've
done podcasts you've done books you did
dirty jobs you've done these sort of a
documentary style shows you do these
commercials with Ford what do you
attribute your success to I I have a
theory and then I have a personal story
about when we first met but I would like
to hear you know you toot your own horn
first because you're so likable
I want to tee this up so that you can
brag and immediately make yourself
unlikable alright so let me try and
approach this in the most humble braggy
way I can yeah I was a I was a really
good show host for about 15 years from
like 1990 to 2002 and during that time I
became facile
at impersonating other hosts and so I
was hired a lot uh to work on projects
that were so poorly conceived and
otherwise doomed that no amount of luck
or talent could save them but I always
did a good job and so I had a business
model that allowed me to do well in
Hollywood by identifying losers and
attaching myself to them and then
getting hired again etc etc thanks for
doing that my loser sense is tingling
the tractor beam sucked me right in
sorry continue so so Dirty Jobs was a
miscalculation it was originally three
one-hour specials they lit him up
because I was trying to do a little
tribute to my to my granddad and in that
format of Dirty Jobs I was not a host I
was I was more of a guest and I wasn't
sewers and I was hanging upside down
from bridges and in coal mines and all
these places but I never had to pretend
to know any more than I did and I never
had to try and sound like an expert
consequently I wound up becoming a
pretty good guest although my appearance
on your program might lead some to
conclude otherwise but I know you're
like a vampire I have to invite you in
first right
and then then you won't really do I will
suck the life out of it yes and so and
so what happened on Dirty Jobs was I
realized that I could function as a
guest instead of a host and once the
show blew up I suddenly became a guy who
was really all about managing
expectations so all I had to do on that
show we never shot a second take there
was no real pre-production there was
certainly no writing and acting and
scripting and any of that stuff
it was truly my crew were flies on the
wall
documenting the day that I had in all 50
states many times over and so people
began to know me as a dude who simply
tried I got paid to try right and and
and that saved my bacon well I think
you're actually sort of echoing exactly
what I was going to speak to your
authenticity now when we go to the web
extended by the way remind me so I don't
forget I hosted some really crappy shows
as well some pilots there was one called
beat my dad with MTV I think the NDA has
long since last I don't know I don't
want to bore people with it right now
but it involves Willie Gault and a girl
kicking my ass I'll go back story but I
do think there's an authenticity about
you that you you seem earnestly
interested in learning when I was
watching Dirty Jobs for example it was
something where I felt as though I was
learning along with you and when I first
met you in person and I was just talking
with Anthony Kamiya about this the other
day like I didn't grow up in the
conservative movement you know I was a
comedian and we didn't get Fox News we
didn't get AM radio so now is it Fox
like I didn't really know many people
right I hadn't really seen mostly folks
but I did know Anthony Kamiya I knew Jim
Norton and I met you one time I was here
at the Blais studios a long time ago and
I knew you and I I don't tend to get
starstruck and I won't say was
starstruck then the one time I got
really starstruck was Clint Eastwood and
I met him and he turned around and he
said I'm Clint I was like what do I I
loved you in every which way but loose
like what do you pick from the catalog
so I decide and I walked off and then my
friend was playing an iPhone game and
Clint went by goes so did you rescue the
princess
just like crazy oh that's awesome anyway
so I see Micro for people out there I'll
be able to kind of exalt him a little
bit here because he is humble you're
sitting in everyone's kind of crowding
around you and I didn't want to crowd
you because I could see you were the
celebrity everyone wanted to ask ask you
these questions but I looked over and
you looked at me and you you nodded you
acknowledge me so I thought okay let me
go over say hi I said hey I don't want
to bother you mr. Rowe I know you're
busy
my name's Steven and you said you did
you did that that documentary on Detroit
you said steven crowder yeah and then he
started speaking with me about what you
liked from that piece of content that
I'd created and you took some time there
and that's not very common the only
other celebrity I can say who did that
was when I was young John Candy he took
some time to do home alone lines with me
when I was about six years old so it
seems like you take a genuine interest
in in in people but do you also have an
abnormally efficient memory I'm sorry
what was the question I said to me it
was really special at that time you know
I might have been 22 or something that
you remembered something yeah I had done
well I'm I'm pretty facile with short
term stuff okay you know it was one of
the tools in that in that spasm of
impersonating a host that that came in
handy
I can I can walk into a room of people
and typically remember everybody I meet
for about an hour then it's gone so long
term I tend to disappoint short term I
can create the illusion of genuine
interest and curiosity in your I mean
I'm just completely honest when I'm kind
of out there working that it's all about
random access sure not about long-term
harddrive stuff but your piece on
Detroit was really interesting to me
because I grew up in Baltimore ran
Detroit and Baltimore are a lot like the
people that I featured on dirty jobs
they were unsung they take it in the
neck more often than not and they and
they're waiting for somebody either to
make a persuasive case for their
existence or at least give them a chance
to put their best foot forward
so I thought you did that in a pretty
refreshing way and in some way shape or
form the people that I'm interested in
in our industry yes in in broadcast find
a way to make themselves subordinate to
their guests
I mean Carson was maybe the best yeah
you know I mean these are people who
know that the next day they'll still be
sitting there and a new guest will will
be there right and I didn't it's a form
of grace I think and I didn't have it
for a long time because I didn't have
any certainty of where my next gig was
coming from sure but you know dirty jobs
to fix that and you and you struck me as
a guy early on who realized you know he
was occupying a place in the food chain
of content and and trying to some degree
to take the reverse commute which is
also something that's important to me
too it's not just about doing something
great I get the sense that you look
around and see where everybody's going
and then say well okay but wherever
they're going who cares I'd rather not
be one of the herd I would rather maybe
even go the wrong direction but at least
I'll I'll go it alone
no I just go the wrong direction
generally and I chase my tail okay I
wish I wish I could say there was a
rhyme or reason well let me ask you this
we've already gone up for a while I want
to of course let everyone know your your
book the way I heard it in the podcast
and will go to off here and kind of talk
a little bit more some inside baseball
on broadcasting let me ask you this
because so many people have seen so much
of your content out there mister micro
what would you want your lasting if you
had to pick one your lasting impact if
you wanted to leave people with one
concept or message from what you've done
is there something that you really think
you'd like to be known for because
sometimes it's tough when you've done
many different like Clint Eastwood is a
good example director he's one that he's
won Grammys I think was a honky Tonk Man
actor Wow same with even somebody what
would you want to be remembered for most
yea people confuse me with Clint
Eastwood all the time yes I would well
from an entertainment standpoint a
couple of years ago I read a letter that
my mother wrote to me on Facebook she's
been writing me letters all her life is
a story about how she lost her big blue
person
the Walmart I read this thing on my
kitchen table and I posted it on
Facebook and then I then I went off to
the wars and I came back a few days
later and it had been viewed 128 million
times and for the first time in my
career I mean I just had to laugh that
that video was me like this holding my
cell phone and reading my mom's letter
and I reached a third of the country in
a production that costs zero point zero
dollars right and and people loved it
they left my mom wound up with a book
deal out of it I wound up with a book
deal so many great things happen because
one day I took the time to read my mom's
letter from my kitchen table totally
this is all way way after Dirty Jobs way
factor everything I don't we posted
about it and I remember so we got so
much positive feedback from it and it
wasn't political it was one of the first
pieces that we ran on our facebook page
at people just said this strikes a chord
with me I remember it well and it was it
was full of lessons and it reminded me a
lot of stuff of a lot of things that I
had already learned but forgotten so on
the entertainment side I'll go with the
peace of random accidental video
inspired by my mom on the earnest side a
foundation came out of Dirty Jobs called
micro works right we've given away over
5 million dollars in work ethic
scholarships and now we've got about 8
or 900 people who have been trained in
the business of learning a skill that's
actually in demand and if there's gonna
be a legacy from any TV project I've
ever done I can't imagine patting myself
on the back any harder then I'll than I
am for that that matters those people
are walking around and I'm you know I'm
proud of them and that was is it micro
works org is that where people can go to
learn more about that that's it you can
apply for a work ethic scholarship or
you can give me money either way
absolutely there's just like the book
the good news there's a give generously
button and it goes wherever you choose I
understand we're a little loosey-goosey
with the rule books no it happens with
me I'll tape some with the studio we
have all these subscribers and then I'll
tape something on my phone and it'll
blow everything else out on the water I
go what am i I should fire all of you I
wake up with this pressure to keep you
employed I don't need you
my roaming charges all right that is
micro of course at micro works the book
is the way I heard it available on
Amazon always worth reading stuff we're
gonna go to a web extended here for
people who are not members of mug club
mr. row please stick around for just a
second here's some music we're gonna
wrap the show up on YouTube
I feel it great but I would like a scalp
meat selsun science your history selsun
blue itchy dry scalp gets to the root of
dandruff and hydrate with five intensive
moisturizers selsun blue itchy dry scalp
don't wear black without the blue that's
a good thing selsun louder with reddish
opcom supports babies we don't kill them
so purchase your baby onesie it louder
with Photoshop calm today
[Music]
that's called the distracted Olympic
diver who realized that our bar is
outfitted with pesos bitters but not
Angostura ah
I just noticed this can you make with
this Eric how did my what am I the the
Cajun from the Green Mile
hey shows Pitters we do have Angus juris
bar is a sham thank you so much to micro
by the way long web extended interview
for those who haven't joined my club
where we just sort of talk some insight
baseball about what it means to be a
man's a lot of our stories in hosting
crappy shows a lot of fun well thank you
I'm glad that you appreciate you
mentioned this to me to I should let you
guys know we're doing the live stream at
Texas A&M on Halloween October 31st to
Halloween spooktacular of course we're
streaming it so it's not just the show
at the venue it will be streamed live
the engine those are always pretty
unpredictable and I would like to say a
lot of fun but I hate myself for the
entire duration up and it's fun when
it's done it is fun it is a hooker we
already have people now actually going
to a.m. and going through the venue and
getting it prepared whole song it's
gonna be a slam-bang show for you bee's
knees come on can you imagine DMX or
exhibit just I'm really trying to get
this started
I'm really trying here throw me a bone
Suge Knight's gonna now Suge Knight's
gonna hang me from a balcony alright
I wanted to revisit something that we
discussed a little bit early in the show
we were talking about the idea of
boundary specifically as it relates to a
tyrannical government by the way I hope
you guys have my back when these clips
get taken out of context no death
threats really clear let me tell you
though I cannot express to you as I grow
older the importance that I've learned
when it comes to boundaries and how
important it is to set them with
finances with work
with relationships establishing them
with others and more importantly with
yourself is as it's about as important
to practice as you can take on
you've got to do it before the imaginary
boundaries get crossed which brings me
to something that that ties into that
and it's been bothering me for a while
this expression we hear a lot and I
heard two people kind of arguing about
it in debate and it was just it was it
was awful the expression an eye for an
eye right now I think some people just
use that expression wrongfully so to
justify acts of our barbarism and they
want to disguise those acts as justice I
think those people are wrong okay but I
do understand the principle of reaping
what you sow but then you have this
other expression and I heard somebody
respond with this and it's a cliche you
know I'm not a huge fan of cliches the
person said well an eye for an eye
leaves the whole world blind but that's
not that's not true either because then
you run into the risk of not issuing any
kind of just punishment or any
punishment at all does anyone think that
that's justice well this guy this guy
murdered a whole family hold on a second
we're not saying eye-for-an-eye murder
his whole family or just saying justice
it could be the death penalty which by
the way don't necessarily support nor am
I really against whatever the cheapest
way is to dispose of this human trash
I'm for as long as they don't get an
Ikea showroom prison cell like they
actually get in Sweden Google Alexander
Gustafsson who was a UFC fighter who
spent time in a Swedish prison it's
nicer than my New York apartment as long
as it's not that whatever you think is
most just here's the thing we have a
justice system in the country why it
consists of word of the day or the day
when you get PJ back in here boundaries
boundaries what we're looking for as
firmly rooted in in natural thus human
rights but this whole expression weird
all the time and I for an eye leaves the
whole world blind I mean it just it just
doesn't even make sense on its surface
it's not both eyes being ripped out of
the face for both other eyes being
ripped out of it that would be blind and
eye for an eye would I mean leave it
would leave the world with some depth
perception issues at worst I'm sure even
a Stan crinch oh that's not a knock but
he would tell he's talked about the
depth issues but I said you can still
function with an eye he's doing well
he's gonna be at a em I believe after us
but two things here hi degress two
things it goes back to all of us due
diligence and setting boundaries the
first group of people who use this
example an eye for an eye they they
mistakenly use it to justify
excessive use of force a lot of people
don't understand and audio weighted
we're talking about this that the
context of an eye for an eye
biblically was about actually putting
limitations on the appropriate reactive
measures to be taken so contextually
again context over content and I for an
eye can be compared to a moral version
of equal and opposite reaction it's
meant to convey that the response should
measure an approximation the action that
required that necessitated the response
in the first place so contextual II it's
actually about setting boundaries the
second group of people who say an eye
for an eye leaves the whole world blind
well they suffer from a lack of
establishing boundaries and we see that
a lot we see it with parents we see it
with citizens we see with politicians
you can't just shoot down a proposed
solution right that has tangibles and
can't concrete because you think it's me
it's on you to say what the equal or
opposite reaction should be because you
know what if you don't take an eye for
an eye
guess what you get you don't get an eye
for an eye you get one guy taking both
eyes and then your nose and then your
ears and your head and your heart I
don't know how he works his way down the
point is this is a sinister guy this
analogy if you don't but in all aspects
of life if you don't push back a little
bit unless there's a little bit of that
tit-for-tat it's not just going to be an
eye it's going to be your life and that
comes back to boundaries we all have
them many of us just don't know that we
have them and so unfortunately our
boundaries kind of become fluid and
that's the thing about setting
boundaries it's it's so important I
cannot express you enough as a society
it's important and more importantly just
as individuals and our personal lives
firmly establishing what it is that you
will and will not do firmly setting
which lines people can and cannot cross
or you will or will not cross about what
is permissible we can expand that to
treatment of others in the United States
setting those boundaries is pivotal if
you if you don't set them in stone ahead
of time you won't know what your
boundaries are until they've been
crossed and that's usually when they've
been long crossed so I want you to do a
simple exercise here this week okay we
need to take out a notepad and paper if
you have an iPad and little stylus
whatever that's called what's that
called stylus I think I got that right
I'm still on the old Palm Pilot
I I want you to take a note pad and
paper I want you to write down two or
three things that you struggle with okay
think about it pause this if you need to
or it could just be things that are
important to you areas where you found
yourself maybe making the same mistake
repeatedly we often do I want you to
take a second think about it is it
relationships maybe with your family
maybe with your wife or your husband is
it your work or life balance is it your
health maybe substance abuse issues I
don't know what it is but I want you to
write it in the middle of the page I
want you to write what it is that you
want to accomplish your end goal I want
you to take inventory and think of what
it is that's hanging you up what is
repeatedly stopping you from achieving
that goal
usually there are a few patterns we all
fall into them now I want you to draw a
square or a circle or a triangle around
the goal of it depending how many
boundaries you set okay this is I want
you to pick some sides here for three
circle I don't care hexagon I don't know
pentagram whatever I want you to write
the boundaries that you set on each side
could be really simple your goal could
be to lose weight and you're going to
write set on that boundary right right
alongside that line desert you set a
boundary that you're not going to have
desert it could be a little tougher
maybe you're having a tough time in your
marriage and you need to set a boundary
on the language you're allowed to use
write that down there in that boundary
once you said it do not under any
circumstances allow that boundary to be
violated by yourself or by other people
against you it may sound trivial but
doing it is so important because
everyone all human beings have a limit
we all have a line in the sand that
can't be crossed and we need to be
honest with ourselves and everyone else
that that line what what it may be
regardless of how uncomfortable it is
because if you don't have that
conversation with yourself and if you
don't set these boundaries if you don't
draw that line in the sand ahead of time
you will be I guarantee you the last to
know that it's been crossed and at that
point it's often too late the good news
is it's easily preventable
take out the guesswork hope that helps
see you next week
[Music]